وقد شهدت مناطق عده بالضفه الغربيه مسيرات
مندده باغتيال العاروري وانطلقت الليله
مسيره شعبيه في مدينه حلحول شمال الخليل
والقيت كلمات نعت الشهيد وبينت دوره
البارزه في وحده الصف الفلسطيني وساحات
المقاومه وتم الاعلان باسم القوى الوطنيه
والاسلاميه عن اضراب شامل اليوم الاربعاء
حدادا على روح الشهيد العاروري
ورفاقه وفي مدينه رام الله شرك العشرات في
المسيره التي جابت شوارع المدينه تلبيه
لدعوات شبابيه فلسطينيه للخروج في مسيرات
بمراكز مدن بمراكز مدن الضفه الغربيه
واعلنت حركه فتح في محافظه رام الله
والبير الاضراب الشامله في المحافظه اليوم
الاربعاء ردا على اغتيال
[تصفيق]
العروره كما تجمع اهالي بلده عروره مسقط
راس الشهيد صالح العاروري شمال مدينه رام
الله امام منزل الشهيد صالح العاروري وسط
هتفات مندده بجريمه
اغتياله
[تصفيق]
سك